Evan you ever see some coffee
shirts um no I'm good okay oh yeah
here's there's no paperwork for you I
already paid a deposit for the first
month just need your signature are you
coming back from vacation oh no I just
got here from Korea actually so you were
on vacation no no it's my first day here
oh nice
I'm from up north North so is that is
that Washington we're gonna balance
Northridge the valley doesn't matter
should we get at him yeah all right okay
all right this place is legit fully
furnished yes
whoa bro what why do you have issues on
what what should I have on well your
feet wear socks my feet or socks will
get dirty
well that's why you don't wear it in the
first place so the floor will won't get
dirty I see this is one of those which
came first the chicken or the egg
scenarios but no doesn't matter what
came first people had their shoes off
dude these are clean right let me just
refresh your memory upon leaving the
coffee shop you stepped on a puddle I
noticed there was a dog nearby a really
good chance that the liquid was from the
dog when we were crossing the street he
stepped on a dead squirrel and a
half-eaten BLT and questionable slam as
we were walking by the bar now imagine
bringing all that into this house we
can't have I know you went to a public
restroom with that shooter that is
disgusting I've lived my entire life
wearing shoes indoors nothing Bad's ever
happened to me no squirrel virus I feel
naked with
it'd be like not wearing underwear plus
I made really good use of the floor mat
outside we're gonna be fine man tie my
shoes here really in Korea we cleaned
the floors every single day and wash our
feet before bed
so thank so the whole country has OCD
you ready all right my phone cars here
[Music]
what are you doing dude I don't want to
lace them up again man
I don't know if that's madness or
dedication
it's except this let's go
[Music]
what is this oh I'm making Korean food I
hope you like tofu know this man what
what is all this
oh this well I went to ecat today and
got inspired me what you can't you know
the furniture store IKEA no it's ECAM
whatever dude what did you you divided
the land you'd rather do that than a one
unified policy here the red lines are my
shoe free zone blue lights are your
shoes on territory and the entrance is
the common area DMZ it's like a giant
game of Twister I've made sure
everything is measured correctly so yeah
fair space did you say tofu yep my
friend do do this okay
I can't even reach the fridge man what
you're building a wall just to be sure
you know what to be fair this is a
country of laws it's nothing personal
man I give up
dude this has gone too far you I'm gonna
take my shoes off here I give up I
surrender you win we're roommates we're
not supposed to be living like enemies
you're right I did take this a little
too far but hey at the end of the day
I'm glad we could come to agreement like
a roommates tear down that wall
[Music]